das in tirol im schnee oberhalb der
gemeinde ein mann der seit über 30
jahren zu den bekanntesten deutschen
gehört
ich fahre blaue bahn rote bahn schwarze
waren das klappt auch alles stürze auch
kaum also in ihr reich lästig um
eingespielt 74 muss er jetzt hier nicht
mehr zu
sein erfolgsrezept ehrgeiz ellenbogen
energie
[Musik]
wie das der kleine männer oft so an sich
haben oder kleine menschen da muss man
halt ein bisschen mehr strampeln
er rettet die staatspartei der ddr vor
dem untergang halb geliebt halb
verteufelt wie wurde der kommunist zum
politstar
wie sie wollten sie schon alle kennen
lernen und wir waren immer ganz stolz
wenn sie nach hause kommen sondern haben
gesagt ich habe ihm die hand gegeben
haben sie ist noch dran obwohl er
extreme positionen bis jetzt habe ich
immer das gefühl gehabt dass er trotzdem
alles eigentlich an einem guter mensch
ist
sein leben lang kämpft er gegen einen
verdacht war er zu nah an der
staatssicherheit
er bestreitet ja nicht mal dass es stasi
akten über hingeben kann nur dass er
wissentlich und willentlich an die stasi
berichtet hat das bestreitet
er gehörte zur funktionärs elite und hat
demzufolge mit dem leben in der ddr fast
nichts zu tun
durch den ukraine krieg wendet er sich
vom alten freund russland ab glaubhaft
oder doch nur politischer wendehals
wissen sie was heißt schon putin
verstehe
wer jetzt sagt wann
wen falsch eingesetzt hat
er gehört zum erbe der ddr verteidigt
sie noch heute
mensch die sie grenzgänger zwischen ost
und west
[Musik]
als kind wollte er schauspieler werden
doch die politik vor dass eine bühne
seit 30 jahren verfolgt er nun seine
lebensaufgabe ost und west versöhnen ich
habe versucht eine einheit dadurch
herzustellen dass ich im westen versucht
habe zu erklären warum der osten so ist
wie er ist und
im osten versucht habe den menschen zu
helfen ihren weg in die einheit zu
finden
dieser weg war und bleibt nicht einfach
august 2021
gysi soll in einem autokino in cottbus
auftreten mal wieder die welt erklären
warum sind sie gekommen weil das unser
lieblings politiker ist und der sagt was
hand und fuß hat dick martys deutsche
wurzeln und ist natürlich von ost noch
da er seit jemanden der auch die politik
sehr nah an ihn bürger bringen kann
ruhig sagen so dass man so auch das ist
der normale auch versteht ja ja ja sagt
alles so sehr deutlich ganz genau und
nicht nicht so verwaschen und nicht so
er antwortet direkt
er soll sein verhältnis zu russland
erläutern an diesem tag ist der krieg in
der ukraine noch fern und gysi russlands
freund der konfrontationskurs der usa
der eu und auch unserer bundesregierung
gegenüber russland übrigens noch
schärfer als gegenüber china arbeit
letztlich gegenüber beiden halte ich für
äußerst unklug ich habe erlebt 2001 wie
putin im bundestag sprach und die
zusammenarbeit auf allen gebieten anbot
und der besten bad zu arrogant
februar 2022 russland überfällt die
ukraine ein klarer bruch des
völkerrechts
gregor gysi entscheidet sich sofort auf
wessen seite er sich stellt gegen den
aggressor er appelliert auf russisch an
putins volk widerstand zu leisten
er besucht die ukraine ohne staatliche
schutzmaßnahmen ohne
öffentlichkeitswirksame termine
aber die ukrainische regierung lässt den
buchstäblich links liegen kein interesse
an dem nach nachfahren sozialistischer
alleinherrscher
in der ukraine empfangen ihn nur kleine
hilfsorganisation
gysi bleibt ein paar tage länger als
andere deutsche politiker
ich bin mit ihm putin regime schifffahrt
ist mit dem regime nichts mehr zu tun es
ist es
verachtet auch die
individuellen rechte der menschen und
das muss aber richtig erst rein in den
kopf in die seele muss das richtig schon
seit 20 jahren so ja das stimmt und das
ist der linken gewinn nicht aufgefallen
doch doch doch nur eine lösung und ich
bin aus bestimmten gründen dagegen dass
deutschland warten liefert aber ich
erkenne das selbstverteidigungsrecht
ukraine an anderen ländern können das
machen die haben eine andere geschichte
als werden er besucht krankenhäuser ist
betroffen von der auswirkung der gewalt
durch russlands militär und trotzdem
bleibt er dabei er ist gegen die
lieferung schwerer waffen aus
deutschland
eine rakete
direkt vor dem haus
im erdgeschoss das alles gut gegangen
dieses politik trifft auch auf
widerstand manche finden ihn immer noch
russlandfreundlich anderen geht seine
distanz nicht weit genug das ist typisch
lese ja da hat dann eben auch den mut zu
sagen ja da habe ich mich gehört ja das
habe ich falsch eingeschätzt diese
fähigkeit sich selbst zu korrigieren das
ist ja im grunde ein leitmotiv in seinem
ganzen in seiner ganzen politischen
karriere
[Applaus]
gregor gysis elternhaus in berlin hier
und jetzt seine ältere schwester
gabriele diese aufnahmen entstehen
während der ukraine reise des bruders
sie sorgt sich um ihnen die reise findet
sie aber falsch eine klare
minderheitsmeinung in deutschland
ich finde die westliche politik die in
den krieg hetzt die aus einer operation
ein krieg macht
unmöglich kriegstreiber risch und gregor
sieht es als jurist und findet dass die
tatsache des angriffskriegs
reicht in der verurteilung
der russischen position und ich finde
das reicht nicht
köpenick die heimat der kiwis gerade ist
er aus der ukraine zurückgekommen und
will seine schwester besuchern heute
noch ist köpenick dieses wahlkreis über
30 jahre nach der wende ist die ddr zwar
verschwunden die erinnerungen aber nicht
hier war die eisdiele holz als ich ein
kind war
[Musik]
und hier waren friseur
alles verschwunden alles anders geworden
nur einer ist geblieben hallo einer von
ihnen
wissen sie
ja wohin sie sich das noch an ja das
frage ich mich auch jetzt frage ich mich
auch hallo
wir wünsche ihnen schöne zeit aber
wissen sie ich kann das eine partie in
einer krise er will dir zu gut gilt
als ist
gregor gysi hat mal rinderzüchter
gelernt studierte dann jura seine
schwester ist schauspielerin und
regisseurin
seitdem ukraine besuch haben sich beide
nicht gesehen die sie ist nervös
hier ist ja offen
also komischerweise aus meiner kindheit
habe ich den garten auf größeren
erinnerung geister ist ja und die garage
wurde anfang gebaut als meine mutter ein
auto bekam also die war nicht von anfang
an dass italien
etwas tun geschwister wenn sie
fundamental anderer meinung sind sie
halten andere daraus oder versuchen es
zumindest
ja ich will aber jetzt mich hier nicht
mit meiner schwester vor ihrer kamera
streit gesagt das vergnügen möchte ich
ihnen spielen man kann sehr stehen
lassen dann haben wir im
unterschiedliche thesen und dann ist es
irgend so dass gregor die welt von einem
bizarren juristischen standpunkt aus
sieht man die methode ist eine andere
ich versuche dann eben bestimmte themen
zu meiden wir streiten uns ja nicht
richtig sie schreibt mir ihre meinung
ich schreibe mir meine meinung die ist
dann höchst unterschiedlich dann schickt
sie mir argumente dann schicke ich ihr
argumente und dann hören wir auf damit
ich kann ziemlich überzeugen sie kann
mich nicht überzeugen lassen hast da es
aber wiederum die geschwisterliche
bindung so wichtig ist würden wir nie an
so was etwas kaputtgehen lassen das
nicht diese bindung hat ihre ursache in
der kindheit die eltern waren
widerstandskämpfer gegen die nazis der
vater später kulturminister der ddr
im keller bewahren sie erinnerungen auf
unendlich viele bücher aber auch das
puppenhaus mit dem gabriele und gregor
gespielt haben die gis waren in der ddr
besser gestellt als andere hatten besuch
aus aller welt ein kindermädchen
der vater ließ sich später scheiden die
kinder hielten zusammen
also wir haben uns schon sehr sehr
gemocht ich glaube das mögen wir immer
noch wir waren privilegiert in dem sinn
dass wir sehr kluge einfühlsame eltern
hatten und dass wir nie in dem sie not
leiden mussten ich war nie in einem
regierungs krankenhaus ich war nie in
einem zk heim oder in einem heim des
ministerrates also das alles diese art
der privilegien hatte ich nicht und ich
war dann genau so eingesperrt wie alle
bürgerinnen und bürger der ddr
der schüler gregor zeigte früh eine
begabung als schauspieler und redner
in den nahen synchron studios durch der
kleine euro ansprechen schaffte es sogar
bis zum hauptsprecher
in dem italienischen film tote und
marcellino spricht wie sie den kleinen
matschie wie no
er sucht rat beim priester des dorfes
wegen seiner kranken mutter
[Musik]
was ist los was willst du
kannst nicht herkommen
wenn wir ins kino ging und ich der
sprecher war ich in dem moment natürlich
sehr wichtig auch in den augen der
anderen und das personal mischung aus
anerkennung und leid
anerkennung heißt heute für self es
still zu halten ganz egal wann und wo
gabriele arbeitet gerade als regisseurin
an einem kreuzberger theater auch gregor
muss auf seine bühne zurück
die ist hier im deutschen bundestag
gregor gysi ist eine der dienstältesten
abgeordneten mit unterbrechung seit über
30 jahren eine zeit lang sogar als
oppositionsführer er akzeptiert heute
auch einen platz in den hinteren reihen
der fraktion hauptsache dabei ich würde
sagen gregor gysi möchte immer
aufmerksamkeit der möchte immer dass
auch das scheinwerferlicht auf ihn
gerichtet ist und dass man ihm zuhört
was er sagt wenn sie wirklich die
bundesstraße verkaufen da sage ich ihnen
was passiert dann werden die länder
anfangen die länder straßen zu verkaufen
da wären die kommunen anfangen die
kommunalstraßen zu verkaufen aber eins
sage ich ihnen als schäuble wenn das je
passieren sollte muss ich ihnen ein
bisschen drohen dann werde ich mit allen
mitteln versuchen die straße zu kaufen
in der sie wohnen für heute für griff
begnadete redner und da muss man ja
nicht überfrachten aber das sollen
ausgesprochen
wirkungsvoller redner ist das ist wahr
außerdem wenn er nicht an die straße um
und es würden in einen keil nächsten
seien immer als schreiben zu müssen dass
sie zum gysi nummer 1 wurden aber das
mache ich dann das ist garantiert ich
habe ihn nicht als feinde angesehen
nächstes nicht
wir sind heute noch politische
mitbewerber dann bin ich es richtig weiß
mitglieder linksparteien nichtmitglieder
cdu
nur bei wenigen gelegenheiten auf sich
gregor gysi geschlagen geben
meist im kampf gegen die uhr
jetzt muss ich mal erklären der
bevölkerung wie das aussieht also ja so
müssen sich aber jetzt jetzt ein
bisschen beeilen rg sie nicht eigentlich
besteht dafür nehme ich gar keine zeit
mehr dann kommt nicht zum abschluss der
bundestagspräsident immer wenn ihr
interessant gesprochen ja sie können
wege wie sie sie könnten ja mit dem
interessanten anfangen dann hätten wir
die nötige zeit
applaus von allen seiten der mama link
links aber ich glaube gießen könnte
jederzeit reduziert die uhr
bundestagsabgeordneter sein unterhalten
wie viel spaß mit
gregor gysi ist heute nicht seine eigene
partei aber er ist seine eigene marke
die marke die sie mit professionellen
mitteln gestaltet aufpoliert unter die
leute gebracht befeuert von einem großen
talent
[Applaus]
ich sage immer du musst mit ihm
irgendwie durchs städtchen gehen und
muss nun eine kiste dabei haben auf die
stellte er sich und wenn er anfängt zu
sprechen ist der platz relativ schnell
voll unabhängig davon ob die leute in
mögen oder nicht mögen
ich glaube würde nur gregor gysi die
politik der linken machen wäre es noch
mehr grund für viele ihn zu wählen
ich glaube das ist gerade auch die
schwäche der linken
ich denke es ein bisschen nah dran beim
sbb und gulden am ende versucht jährigen
kapitalismus so ein bisschen besser zu
machen oder sozialer zu machen also mir
fällt ein das hätte die ddr nicht als
unrechtsstaat bezeichnen kann das das
erste was mir einfällt
berlin vierter november 1989 die bislang
größte demonstration gegen die mächtigen
der ddr wie sie darf als vorsitzender
der anwaltskammer sprechen und lernt was
bei den leuten zieht erst der witz dann
die inhalte die marke die sie entsteht
an diesem tag
liebe freunde ich
spreche eigentlich frei
ich habe es mir diesmal aufgeschrieben
damit ich auch danach noch weiß was ich
gesagt habe
meine brille war größer als heute und
wissen sie woran das lag dass sich die
verkleinert scheibe weil ich mal in der
talkshow mit herrn fielmann zusammen war
und jetzt sagte ihre brille ist so groß
und hat eine kleinere mitgebracht und er
hat mich überzeugt seitdem trage ich
kleine gruppe
[Applaus]
sie nehmen mir meine kurze redezeit
worüber er gesprochen hat ist lange
vergessen aber den freundlichen lustigen
anwalt den vergessen sie nicht und nur
wenige trauen ihm nicht den sohn eines
hohen funktionärs
damals ging es mir und vielen
oppositionellen freunden so dass man bei
ihm den eindruck hatte dass da jemand
probiert schnell das rettende ufer zu
erreichen
denn ich glaube gregor gysi war jemand
der vielleicht etwas er wurst als andere
dass es mit der sed-diktatur zu ende
gehen würde
dezember 1989 die mauer ist weg die
sozialistische einheitspartei aber noch
da parteitag es geht um alles auflösen
verändern gar nichts machen
im komitee zur vorbereitung des
parteitags sitzt auch gregor gysi man
sucht einen nachfolger für die spitze
und plötzlich sagten die alle ich soll
das werden und da habe ich sie gefragt
ob es dem knall haben ich bin anwalt und
so weiter und dann rechts hessen sehr
offen mich ein und in der schwächsten
sekunde meines lebens habe ich dann ja
gesagt
das hat ja natürlich erst ein bisschen
naja meint
ich hatte also so sehr hat es war
raffiniert
[Gelächter]
die sed entdeckt die demokratie bedrängt
von den eigenen leuten
angefeindet von westdeutschen medien
wählen sie ihre zukunft
95 für gysi und sein versprechen für den
bestand der ddr zu kämpfen die partei zu
reorganisieren
das bringt ja fast ikonografische bild
wo er mit dem besen in der hand steht
und die sed aus kehrt das ist ja mit ihm
verbunden walter ulbricht erich honecker
egon krenz
gregor gysi im jahre 91 hat er mich mal
im innenministerium besuchte heute
gefragt ob formale opera es war ja klar
und dann hat mich mein team gespräche da
musste ich schaff's doch zahlen lagen
hat er gesagt haben sie mal
wie war denn eigentlich so der honecker
sie haben denn doch gekannt
wie
war denn der honecker so als mensch das
fand ich irgendwie so lustig dass man
weil lachen müssen weil ich ja
theoretisch der nachfolger war aber er
kannte ihn und ich könnte ihnen eben
nicht
den fortbestand der partei hatte gysi
erkämpft die ddr konnte er nicht retten
im sommer 1990 stimmte die letzte
volkskammer der ddr für die vereinigung
gegen den willen der einstmaligen
staatspartei
das parlament hat soeben nicht mehr
nicht weniger
hat sie in untergang der deutschen
demokratischen republik zum dritten
oktober
geschlossen
in die ddr wie sie auch immer historisch
beurteilt werden wird war für jeden von
uns mit sehr unterschiedlichen
erfahrungen dass bisherigen leben
gregor gysi entwickelt einen neuen
markenkern immer daran erinnern woher
man kommt und was man hatte
die ddr hat politisch ausgegrenzt über
auch nicht demokratisch über auch nicht
freiheitlich aber sie war sozial
gerechter
sein mantra dass sie noch heute
popularität garantiert er ist sozusagen
das denkmal der ddr in all ihren
facetten
frühjahr 2022 bürgerfest in gregor gysi
es wahlbezirk wenig
[Musik]
was
verstehst du dass es menschen gibt die
grünen
tätig den gregory sie finde charmant
intelligent unterhaltsam
und klug wenn ich sage das jetzt immer
in allen dingen recht hat aber
ich finde er belebt die debatte er ist
jetzt ein bisschen lange dabei doch
manchmal denke ich dann auch mal jemand
mal nachrücken er hat ja damals bei den
quali kumpeln gewesen bei diesem streik
und hat eine ganz positive rolle
gespielt ja
man kann ihm vieles vorwerfen aber nicht
dass er sich zu wenig für die belange
aus deutschlands eingesetzt hätte
als anfang der 1990 er jahre die
kaliwerke bischofferode trotz guter
marktchancen geschlossen werden sollten
zeigte er sich oft bei den streikenden
[Musik]
die bundesregierung hat sich eben für
sie der ermisch interessiert sie hat er
die ddr im kalten krieg
besiegt und die gegend unter das der
punkt und das hat das selbstbewusstsein
runter gedrückt
fast drei millionen
industriearbeitsplätze abgebaut 14
prozent arbeitslosigkeit
wochen lang streikten die bischofroda
kumpel am ende vergebens auch ihr werk
wurde geschlossen
ich fand ihn so mutig ich fand es ja
doch sehr mutig in dieser zeit wo man ja
wenn man es böse formulieren möchte
das ist eigentlich war der osten die
verliererseite im osten war der große ja
fast schon also führt das milieu der
menschen die im grunde die ddr nicht
abgelehnt hatten und zumindest den
sozialismus nicht abgelehnt haben die
hatte er war hanne geradezu der
heilsbringer
die partei neu erfinden die menschen vor
zuviel zukunft schützen wie sie es
aufgabe war riesig vielen schien sie
unmöglich
[Musik]
die partei musste ihr vermögen abgeben
riesige steuer beträge nachzahlen den
apparat abwickeln und trotzdem
existierte sie weiter als pds partei des
demokratischen sozialismus und dem ihr
lebte die ddr weiter
ja im ddr sozialismus gab es schwächen
und gab es auch schlimme dinge und doch
war die ddr mein land und stand ich
früher zu ihr und tue dies auch heute
und wenn wir dafür stalin ismus
vorgeworfen wird so muss ich damit leben
die bruchlinie der pds und aller
nachfolger sahra wagenknecht war wurde
damals ja vorsitzende der
kommunistischen plattform und stand
dafür all das zu erhalten an der partei
was die sie ändern wollte die bereiteten
uns permanent schwierigkeiten im
erneuerungsprozess
weil sie immer noch zum teil an der
alten ideologie hin
die zerstrittene kinder gehören sie doch
zusammen obwohl sie vieles trennt die
sie störte vor allem die glorifizierung
der sowjetunion
es sind millionen menschen umgebracht
worden und darunter die größte zahl von
kommunistinnen und kommunisten die je in
einem land ermordet worden sind das ist
eine tatsache ob man schon mal nein zu
sagen und zwar auch deutlich
dafür gibt es applaus aber keinen jubel
diese umbenennung das war für mich immer
nur wie tarnung ja also um wegzukommen
von dem image wir nennen uns mal anders
wir versuchen andere leute noch mit
einzufangen und vielleicht werden die
leute irgendwann vergessen wer wir mal
gewesen sind gerade dadurch dass gysi
die pds damals noch in den bundestag
geführt hat hat er vielleicht mehr zum
integration ostdeutschlands in die
bundesweiten die gesamtdeutsche
bundesrepublik beigetragen als viele
andere die sich politisches gewicht
lässt sich messen in wahlergebnissen
seine parteien krebsen mehr oder weniger
immer um die fünf prozent hürde herum er
selbst erzählt in seinem wahlkreis
ergebnisse über die sich jede
volkspartei freuen würde
zu den wurzeln der marke die sie gehört
auch seine lebenslange liebe zum fußball
club union berlin
gregor gysi ist schon lange mitglied mit
dauerkarte
wir haben sie hier das auto wiesen oder
wir haben das auto leasen
den spruch
fußball hat die deutschen vielleicht
mehr zusammengebracht als alles andere
und auch wie sie hat freunde wo man es
nicht vermuten würde
ja wir haben uns mal bei einem
fußballspiel in berlin bei hat er im
stadion zufällig getroffen und da saßen
kurze zeit zusammen und ich hatte das
gefühl dass da die chemie gleich
gestimmt hat
im gegensatz zu hoeneß kennt die seine
grenzen im fußballgeschäft ganz genau
na ja also ich sage ich bin ja gerne rad
ist also ich kann über alles reden ohne
davon einer kenntnis zu haben aber
trainer da musst du nun natürlich kennt
man das haben sie habe ich die
wichtigkeit der verein galt zu ddr
zeiten schon als verdächtig die fans als
subversiv einige hat die sie damals
schon vor gericht vertreten wegen
rowdytum oder staatsfeindlicher
agitation inzwischen gehören beide zum
establishment
gespräche die wir geführt haben hat er
sich als absoluter union sind
herauskristallisiert und ich hatte ihnen
auch mal zu einem spiel eingeladen ich
glaube es war sogar gegen union und da
hat er sich natürlich noch mal dahin
gesetzt auf unsere haupttribüne und
das war schon mutig
mutig sein aber das risiko kalkulieren
so steuert die sie seine karriere
erschafft spannende bilder er findet
einfache texte
[Musik]
weil er in parlamenten seiner meinung
nach nicht ausreichend gehört wird geht
er eben im fernsehen niemand hat
nachgezählt wie oft er gast in talkshows
war und ob er überhaupt eine ausgelassen
hat heikel ist er kein zweifel aber
jetzt nicht so dass einen das stört
das kann man ertragen wenn man mit ihnen
persönlich auch zusammensetzt kann man
es ganz gut beschreiben ich würde sagen
der räder anteil ist 90 zu 10 das ist
nicht so dass herr gysi keine fragen
stellen nur meistens beantwortet er die
dann auch gleich selber die sie hat
heute vier berufe politiker anwalt
schriftsteller talkmaster die shows sind
politisch harmlos die gäste kommen gerne
vielen dank ich hab's vermutet dass sie
links sitzen das dach die mischung ja
ich war ja selten einen menschen
kennengelernt der so viele eigenarten
auf sich vereint und auch sozusagen
gezielt nutzt und damit auch ankommt
also er ist profitiert das ausgewogen
verständnis für auch mal wenn es hart
auf hart geht um mal ganz knallhart vor
den kopf stoßen
nicht alle haben ihn geschätzt wenig
bekannt ist dass es morddrohungen gab
und 1997 sogar ein missglücktes attentat
das hält ihn nicht von seinen
regelmäßigen bürgersprechstunden ab eine
der schwierigsten disziplinen im leben
eines politikers denn zu diesen
gelegenheiten kommen nur menschen mit
sorgen
nur ganz selten verliert er die geduld
etwa angesichts eines papierstapel den
er doch bitte lesen um zur kenntnis
nehmen soll aber schon allein da was
glauben sie wie viel zeit ich brauche
das durchzuarbeiten
bevor ich sie nehmen so vielleicht kann
ihnen das land
es werden was meinen sie wie viele leute
mir so viel papier in die hand überall
wo ich bin ja man sagen sie müssen das
unbedingt lesen ja ich bin nur ein
mensch verstehen sich bin ich zwölf
menschen
die erfahrungen die ich gemacht habe ist
dass er natürlich sehr eloquent und auch
sehr intelligent es verstand themen
aufzugreifen die wirklich mit den
brüchen von ddr-biografien dann auch im
zusammenhang standen was aber soll es
sagen von ihm immer im wesentlichen
ausgeblendet war dass das genau die
hinterlassenschaft des systems war in
dem er ein besonderes privileg erfahren
hatte es gab nur 600 zugelassene anwälte
in der ddr sie bestreitet dass ihn sein
vater protegiert hätte die fälle seien
ihnen zugeteilt worden
auch gregor gysi verteidigte
regime-gegner ein heikles spiel mit der
stadt justiz ein dauerndes verhandeln
mit den schatten männern von der stadt
sicherheit fast 200.000 menschen führte
das ministerium damals als inoffizielle
mitarbeiter
wer ins gefängnis kam und wer nicht war
oft reine willkür die sie verteidigte
prominente dissidenten hatte etwas über
sie verraten und wem allein schon die
nähe zu den staatsorganen nehmen ihm
noch heute viele übel
nach der wende untersuchungsausschüsse
zahlreiche titelstorys klagen gegen
klagen obwohl ihnen gerichte immer
wieder recht gaben sie fühlten sich
verfolgt und verleugnet alle die sie
wissen sie aber auch eine wut auf die
die auf unbewiesenen behauptung meinem
sohn etwas anhängen wollen das können
sie einer mutter ja nicht verdenken die
mutter glaubt immer ihrem kind ich
erinnere mich an eine rede da hat er
gesagt ich weiß gar nicht warum sie
glauben dass ich irgendwie ein
informelles verhältnis zur stadt
sicherheit haben musste ich hatte ein
offizielles verhältnis und zwar ein
regelmäßiges hat er gar nicht drum herum
geredet ja ich war zu keinem zeitpunkt
dm der staatssicherheit das wäre für
mich auch gar nicht in frage warum aber
natürlich habe ich mit denen gespräche
geführt zum beispiel über
haftbedingungen über alles mögliche was
meine mandanten betraf und letztlich
habe ich habe von den gerichten und auch
von der staatsanwaltschaft recht
bekommen naja gregor gysi ist ja ein
mensch der sicherlich seine eigene sicht
auch der dinge hat also leicht
erschüttert ihn auch nichts und er hat
da seine legende er hat seine geschichte
die erzählt und jandy erzählt er jetzt
ja auch schon sehr lange zeit
die sie bekamen wieder negative
schlagzeilen als er der regierung
wowereit in berlin beitrag zum ersten
und einzigen mal in einem regierungsamt
als wirtschaft sein
sein chef schickt ihn erst mal zum
aktenstudium
ja gut das musste erst auch mal lernen
also ist ein unterschied ob du dann als
bundestagsabgeordneter ausgebuht den
torschuss gehst und denn da die sprayer
verbreiten kannst oder ob du da von
morgens bis abends arbeiten muss und der
hart gearbeitet also wer hat noch nachts
da noch gesessen das amt behält er nicht
lange die sie nutzt seine bonusmeilen
aus dienst flügen privat der
wirtschaftssenator wirtschaftet unsauber
der vorwurf trifft ihn hart
natürlich will seinen das auf aber wenn
du darfst hier nicht zu sehr anmerken
lassen weil sonst werden die angriffe
immer schlimmer dann muss wenigstens so
tun als ob es dir fast gleichgültig ist
das habe ich auch gelernt
aber es fällt mir schwer weil ich mich
nicht gerne verstellen er hätte nicht
wegen dieser affäre zurücktreten
müssen ich glaube es war für ihn auch
ein willkommener anlass sich von dieser
bürde zu befreien ich glaube hat er die
notbremse gezogen
wohl auch aus privaten gründen
gregor gysi heiratet in seinem leben
zweimal bekommt zwei kinder adoptiert
später ein drittes eine zeit lang ist
alleinerziehend er erträgt einsamkeit
nicht so gut sagt er selbst
[Musik]
gregor er ist auf seine weise absolut
attraktiv und ich glaube hat auch ein
gewisses frauen verständnis na ja die
frauen musste ich natürlich auch sehr
sonst wäre ich ja nicht geheiratet ich
war bisher zweimal verheiratet und bin
auch zweimal geschieden ich bin
persönlich aber nie privat
also sie erfahren natürlich zeit ist
zweimal geschieden bin aber nicht warum
ich nehme gregor gysi so war dass sein
politisches leben sein privatleben ist
und er hat der politik auch fast alles
untergeordnet
auch seine gesundheit die sie erleidet
herzinfarkte haus sich operieren lassen
doch 2005 kehrte in den bundestag zurück
und auch dorthin wo er sich vielleicht
am wohlsten fühlt in den fond eines
dienstabend
sucht das café
der rücksitz des dienstwagens ist sein
wohnzimmer gregor gysi hört gerne musik
besonders gerne klassik auf keinen fall
aber top radio
damit besserte
wir fahren jetzt sehr der tiefgarage und
jeden der modell kaffee trinken weil der
kaffee plus 150 meter weiter und dann
sollte nicht allzu viel taugen
und hier findet der ob die veranstaltung
damit stand
[Musik]
es dürfte keinen ort in deutschland
geben in dem die sie noch nicht
gesprochen hat
2009/10 galt er als der abgeordnete mit
den meisten bezahlten nebentätigkeiten
ein kongress für finanzdienstleistungen
hat ihn eingeladen er kommt gerne nicht
nur weil es mutmaßlich gut bezahlt ist
und es dass sie 1990 sonstwas dafür
gegeben hätten mich nie zu sehen und es
ist für mich ein stück tut dass sie mich
jetzt einladen
ein herzlicher applaus für doktor gregor
gysi
den weg mit der genugtuung findet
bewegend dass er ihnen gleich noch mal
einen schönen guten tag meine damen und
herren ich genieße ihren beifall schon
deshalb weil ich mir vorstelle wie der
1990 ausgefallen wäre
soziale gerechtigkeit ein bisschen
umverteilung verständnis für den osten
immer dasselbe stück die sie ist ein
politischer klassiker geworden
die politiker wenn die reden rhetorisch
fit sind dann ja klingt wie eine gute
und richtige zu sagen also stimme viel
aussagen von der gew zu aber ich bin
jetzt kein fern der linken partei ist
ein anderer linker als man vielleicht im
kopf hat was links sein könnte dass die
partei die linke gegründet
gysi und seine vision linker politik
eine gesamtdeutsche marke links von der
spd ohne ostdeutsche befindlichkeiten
ohne westdeutsche arroganz an der spitze
zwei etwa gleich große männer beide
intellektuelle beide begabte redner
beide nicht besonders gut darin macht zu
teilen
gregor gysi und oskar lafontaine
sie sind eben alle artisten
wird es ist natürlich so dass später
rolle es gab damals dieses berühmte
wahlplakate beide sind ja keine großen
männer sondern von körperliche statur
her klein wo sie aber so aufgenommen
wurden das die eso ein bisschen zu oskar
lafontaine aufblickt und er grinst so
ein bisschen hoch das hat er mir übel
genommen dieses plakat habe ich ohne
seine genehmigung in druck gegeben
es konnte nicht gutgehen wenn die linke
eines kann dann sich in alte zeiten und
vergangenheits debatte zermürben
reichensteuer umverteilt ländern ukraine
auch heute weiß man nicht so recht wofür
die linke genau steht wenn meine partei
muss
endlich in den medien deutlich machen
was es mehrheitsmeinung was
minderheitsmeinung die denunziation die
in einem maße um sich greift das es
unerträglich kann ich nur sagen das muss
beendet werden
diese unfähigkeit zur inneren einheit
nehmen immer mehr wähler übel
september 2021
bundestagswahl
das wird ein wahlkrimi heute abend die
linke mit 5 prozent und deutlichen
verlusten das kann noch eine hängepartie
werden heute abend
drei gewonnenen direktmandate ist es zu
verdanken dass die linke noch lebt und
sogar als fraktion im bundestag sitzt
eines davon hat er gewonnen mal wieder
wie immer
gut dann sage ich euch das ergebnis dass
wir bundesweit erzielen werden ist
desaströs und man muss darüber überhaupt
nicht diskutiert wir sehen sie denn die
linken jetzt gerade im moment in welchem
zustand
gibt es die ordnung
das ist eben auf der abschiedstour
nächsten bundestag kann man dies
sicherlich nicht mehr ich habe auch
alles so viel getan ja sie haben kein
fettnäpfchen ausgelassen
was wäre die linke ohne ein gregor gysi
also erstmal wir müssen uns auch daran
gewöhnen dass eine linke auch ohne
gregor gysi und auch ohne bodo ramelow
existieren können muss sie muss auf den
anspruch haben das zu wollen wenn er
dieser partei den rücken kehren würde
oder wenn er wirklich mal nicht mehr da
ist ist sie definitiv ärmer
was hat er erreicht eine partei gerettet
eine gegründet er hat viel für die
innere einheit deutschlands getan aber
möglicherweise zu wenig für die innere
einheit seine partei
die zeiten kommen und gehen regierungen
kommen gehen gregor gysi möchte bleiben
als sprecher für außenpolitik seit dem
einmarsch russlands in die ukraine hat
seine rolle wieder an bedeutung gewonnen
und die marke gysi sieht immer noch auch
präsidentin liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen also ich finde das auswärtige
amt könnte umbenannt werden in ein auf
rüstungs waffenexport und sanktions
ministerium das lässt die
regierungskoalition nicht auf sich
sitzen der gegenangriff erfolgt prompt
mit hinweis auf die lange gepflegten
guten beziehungen der linken zu russland
in welchen zentralkomitee sind diese
rede heute geschrieben worden ich kann
ihnen nur sagen wenn sie denken dass das
funktioniert dann nutzen sie bitte die
sehr guten kontakte nach ostern in den
kreml die viele von ihnen auch haben so
geht es seit über 30 jahren immer
dieselben angriffe immer dieselbe
machtlosigkeit seiner kleinen partei
ich nenne das immer krankheiten sind
natürlich keine zwei krankheiten an mir
festgestellt dass eine ist dass sich
doch wirklich preuße stuhr werde ich
kämpfe um eine akzeptanz und wenn ich
die erreicht habe dann sieht das ganz
anders aus und die zweite krankheit das
wusste ich auch nicht wie leute
interessieren mich immer erst wenn sie
probleme haben also das klappt
bundesminister mit denen habe ich gar
kein wort gewechselt die mit mehr auch
nicht und plötzlich wurden sie
angegriffen und angefeindet und dann
sprach ich mit ihnen erwischt werden ich
mir überlegt warum eigentlich ja weil so
ein problem hat wie sie heute ein
bisschen mittendrin ein bisschen mit
dabei seine fallende sind müde geworden
oder einfach nicht mehr da
[Musik]
kann er aufhören das weiß ich auch nicht
ich hoffe dass es keine krankheit ist
die ihn dazu zwingt es ist so dass er
eben gerne arbeitet dass er gerne über
die welt nachdenkt und dann in der welt
wirken möchte insofern gibt es keinen
grund aufzuhören
aber gysi spürt die belastung oft gibt
der ämter auf weil er nicht mehr kann
wie 2015 er wirft den fraktionsvorsitz
im bundestag hin
ich habe viel zu wenig freundschaften
gepflegt
ich hatte viel zu wenig zeit für meine
angehören es lag an mir weil ich zu
selten nein sagt sagte mich einfach zu
wichtig es tut mir sehr sehr leicht
er ist gegangen aber nur um zu bleiben
[Applaus]
irgendwie hat es doch geschafft über die
jahrzehnte jetzt doch irgendwie ja
mittlerweile schon fast aller statement
zu sein also die anerkennung hatte
[Musik]
wohl deswegen denkt er auch heute nicht
ans aufhören und bleibt er ein etwa 64
kleiner große gregor gysi
der letzte tag im schnee die letzte
abfahrt das letzte bisschen ruhe
[Musik]
oder beginnt für mich damit dass ich
keine zeitungen lese und dann lasse ich
in der regel mein handy im hotel weil
ich telefonieren will und nichts und
wenn ich dann wieder zurückkommen und
dann schaue ich mir die nachrichten an
dann will ich wieder ein bisschen dabei
[Musik]
einmal stand in der zeitung etwas das
sein politisches leben auf einen satz
verdichtet
das ist nicht witzig nicht fröhlich aber
er selbst fasst es so zusammen
[Musik]
ja am meisten und am erfolglosesten
verfolgte politiker deutsche politiker
heißt krise der am meisten und am
erfolglosesten verfolgte deutschen
politiker heißt träger wie finde ich mir
einen schönen satz fällt nicht drauf
gekommen
über 30 jahre in der politik
der mensch gysi hat viel gewonnen und
auch viel eingesteckt
vielleicht macht beides die marke gießen
so erfolgreich
[Musik]